i wanted to watch a little bit somebody
sent me this six years ago they did like
this very weird and rt covered at this
very strange
um
ceremony for the opening of a tunnel in
switzerland
and it really did you know you know
obviously a lot of people send you
things to go oh it's an illuminati
ritual it's an illuminati ritual
and a lot of it's you know hokum
a lot of it's you know crazy and there's
they're making this big stretch it's a
leap it's a jump
uh not not so much here because this one
isn't incredibly disturbing
and hilarious
by the way so
people from switzerland are just
terrifying
uh can we see that on the screen
so
by the way so
and i i don't know if this has been
covered a bunch maybe it has been
somebody just sent this to me
um
you know what's amazing about all this
this is an opening of like a tunnel it's
completely
like unnecessary it could it could have
been like a ribbon cutting ceremony just
a real plain
you know basically something that's
ignored but instead they do this crazy
hour-long ceremony where they have like
baomat
dancing around like guys and goats heads
and everything play a little bit of this
ben and then play play some of the
uh you know um
uh what you may call it uh what are they
called when you save something in a
minute time stamp yeah some of the more
disturbing time stamps here they're just
it's it's it's really funny it's so long
yeah okay i'll just start at the
beginning here because this is just and
the music's insane too
yeah
and this is at a obviously a faster spin
yeah yeah i'm gonna should i just leave
it on faster i guess yeah yeah
this is just how it starts right here
cloud schwab was like we're going all
the way this time
we don't give a [ __ ]
klaus schwab's like every now and then
we just go hard yeah you know every now
and then we just got to go hard like
sometimes get go go to some more of the
other stuff yeah this stuff right here
yeah opening of a tunnel
slow this down okay
this is really like
where you just go oh
this is insane
[Music]
can you like imagine
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i mean these are the guys in hostel in
the movie hostel who drill through the
girl's eye yeah yeah and they're just
sitting there and they're watching this
i mean this is one of the most insane
things i've ever seen in my life
[Music]
this is the uh
this is the jizzling maxwell memorial
service
he's yodeling this is the yodeling
pedophile
this is the
this is the yodeling pedophile
a uh character from swiss uh mythology
okay so once they then they have the
pope there's a whole thing but the pope
comes yeah the pope
uh very popular pope makes a cameo for
the opening of a tunnel i mean
what what is going on here
why
why is the pope
what is the pope doing here
this is like these guys have these weird
bird cages like on their heads i mean
this this whole thing's weird
and then uh
this is as they're moving outside then
the pope comes in at like some point is
your children like dressed as angels
yeah there's the pope you can see him on
the car is that the real pope no not the
real one oh that's not the real post no
no i don't know it's a fake pope there
he is
oh that's not the pope that's cloud
schwab
okay so once they get outside uh so i'm
gonna go to 3420 here this gets a little
nuts right here so they're climbing this
they're pretending to climb this rock
wall and that's right falling and dying
another one naked yeah and then they all
uh this robe here
these dudes are hung is this the way
switzerland's doing it jesus
i didn't know swiss had huge dicks
so now
i i guess this is uh and they're all in
the dust here and i have no idea what's
gonna be can you imagine
if you were just like yeah we're going
to some ribbon cutting samurai okay here
we go now we got the creepy nuns yeah
yeah
here we go this is i mean this is this
is an a24 movie
here we go
this is worse than a24 this is by the
way it's better than an 824 movie let's
be let's be honest
hereditary was [ __ ]
they found some creepy girl
that's all hereditary was they just
found this girl that you know
face looked like a tuna sandwich
i mean is i mean
you know some of the illuminati people
are sitting there going okay this is too
much
we went too far here
they were like we said
we wanted notes of this
we said let's touch on the themes
lightly
uh we were supposed to touch on the
themes of enslaving the human race
lightly
this is a bit heavy-handed
no
what do you mean i'm doing exactly what
you asked
you have people in bug costumes
you don't think this is a bit
heavy-handed
keep going this is crazy okay so this is
the uh this park this is they're kind of
gearing up for the finale here right
so here comes the uh the goat the goat
makes a
comes back here
[Music]
yeah i mean i it's just
really confusing
[Music]
how many views does this have is this
something that's like known do people
know about this
this has only 700 000 views from six
years ago yeah
yeah
yeah this is you know and then uh so
then the finale here is the goat lady it
looks like and this is the most watched
part the most replayed yeah this one
here yeah yeah right here this is like a
mural from the denver airport came to
life
[Music]
you're right though it's kind of like
mid-summer almost it's it's
well this is your whole thing now you
have like a
goat who's
looks like a trans goat
[Music]
and then i'm just going to skip to the
finale here because that part was here's
the positive there's two possibilities
here number one this is 100 an
illuminati production number two really
america is the only country that should
ever make like any type of artistic
music or anything like this is like if
this is what they do if this wasn't
directed
by like bilderberg child eating serpents
that's even more disturbing like if this
is just what
they thought would be good
if this is them we've got a bigger
problem
oh yeah so this is the finale i think
the whole thing they're trying to say
like time is god so they're like they
show the clock there
you see this clock
oh they're all seeing a countdown
because it saves so much time because
they can go through the swiss house they
could go through the tunnel yeah
right so
yeah who can go through the tunnel yeah
so it's like time is god and then it
goes crazy and then this is the big uh
hurrah at the end you see the the
you see it go out of the tunnel here
[Music]
that's the train of the children
to be sacrificed
[Applause]
i like one of them was doing a fortnight
dance yeah you see that one of them was
doing a fortnight i mean you see man
you just can't keep us out of anything
we'll invade even the illuminati ritual
with our [ __ ]
we just pop up all right well that was
nice
that tunnel right there the gothard
tunnel
someone who you know who sends me a lot
of things and won't say who i i know who
you're talking sent me that and i
thought that was interesting and i
watched it and now we've played it on
the show